Calcula la suma de 15 + (-46) + 29. Pensemos
en esta primera parte donde tenemos 15 + (-46),
nos preocuparemos por el + 29 más tarde, así que
hagamos 15 + (-46). Permíteme dibujar una recta
numérica aquí sólo para que podamos visualizar
adecuadamente lo que está sucediendo. Esta es mi
recta numérica, dibujemos un 0 aquí y comenzamos
en 15, el 15 puede estar aquí. Permíteme dibujar
una flecha grande y gruesa para indicar que
esto es 15, 15 tiene un valor absoluto de 15,
por lo que la longitud de esta flecha será 15.
Ahora queremos sumar 46 negativo a ese 15, esto
es equivalente a 15 - 46, lo que significa que
nos vamos a mover 46 lugares a la izquierda del
15. Un signo negativo o menos significa que nos
movemos hacia la izquierda en la recta numérica.
Vamos a movernos 46 a la izquierda, comenzamos
en el 15 y vamos a movernos 46 a la izquierda,
entonces la longitud de esta flecha será 46
y nos estamos moviendo hacia la izquierda,
este es el 46 negativo que estamos sumando a 15.
Vamos a terminar en algún lugar por aquí, en ese
punto es claramente negativo porque estábamos 15
a la derecha. Ahora vamos a movernos 46 hacia la
izquierda, así que definitivamente vamos a estar
a la izquierda de 0, definitivamente será un
número negativo e incluso podemos pensar en el
valor absoluto de ese número negativo. Podemos
simplemente visualizarlo: esta flecha amarilla
tiene una longitud de 15, esta flecha anaranjada
tiene una longitud de 46, la flecha azul que
estoy a punto de dibujar es la suma de estos dos,
va a tener esta longitud, y sólo visualmente ¿cómo
podemos calcular la longitud de esta parte azul si
conocemos la longitud de esta parte anaranjada
y conocemos la longitud de esta parte amarilla?
Bueno, va a ser la diferencia, sólo será la
diferencia de estos dos, entonces el valor
absoluto de la suma será la diferencia entre esta
longitud 46 y 15. Permíteme calcularlo: 46 - 15,
6 - 5 es 1, 4 - 1 es 3, entonces esta longitud
va a ser 31, y va a ser 31 a la izquierda de 0,
por lo que esto será 31 negativo justo aquí.
Sabemos que esta primera parte es 31 negativo,
y luego a eso vamos a sumar 29. Permíteme hacer
esto en otro color. ¿Qué significa esto? Pues
significa que vamos a comenzar en 31 negativo
y vamos a movernos 29 a la derecha, estamos
sumando 29, así que nos vamos a mover 29 hacia
la derecha. Estoy tratando de dibujar una flecha
de 29 de longitud. Vamos a mover el 29 hacia la
derecha, esa es la longitud de 29. Ahora bien,
este es un 29 positivo, entonces ¿cómo calculamos
esto? Este es el 29 que estamos agregando,
nos llevará hasta acá en la recta numérica, ¿cómo
calculamos qué número es este? Bueno, una vez más
podemos simplemente visualizarlo y después no
tendrás que dibujar rectas numéricas y estas
cosas, pero creo que es útil aquí. Comenzamos
en 31 negativo, le estamos agregando 29,
entonces será negativo, estamos sumando
menos de 31 por lo que no llegaremos a 0,
seguiremos teniendo un número negativo. Pero ¿cómo
podemos averiguar el valor absoluto de este número
negativo, su distancia? Bueno, una vez más esa
pequeña parte blanca de ahí, esa parte blanca más
este 29 va a ser igual a 31. Si sólo pensamos en
el valor absoluto, si no pensamos en los signos,
si sólo pensamos en la longitud u otra forma es
31 - 29, que nos dará la longitud de esa parte
blanca, y por supuesto será negativo, porque este
número negativo es mayor que este número positivo.
Si tomamos 31 y restamos 29, puedes pedir prestado
y todo eso, pero claramente será igual a 2,
puedes decir que este es 11, esto es un 2,
restas esto es igual a 2; pero dado que es
31 negativo más 29 será 2 negativo. El resultado
seguirá siendo negativo. No nos hemos movido lo
suficiente a la derecha como para pasar 0,
así que esto de aquí será 2 negativo. Otra
forma de verlo es que la longitud de esta barra
blanca, el valor absoluto será 2, 2 + 29 es 31,
pero estamos operando a la izquierda de 0, por lo
que es 31 negativo y esto es 2 negativo. Espero
que esto te sea útil, y permíteme dejarlo
más claro: la respuesta final es 2 negativo.